[Music]  we're talking about her books because an  fine is coming to mrs. Doubtfire tells  the story a couple who are recently  divorced and they have three children  the ex-wife does not want the husband to  spend as much time with the children as  he would like and so what does he do he  dresses up as a woman called Madame  Doubtfire and goes to live with the  ex-wife as their babysitter the children  of course cotton on straight away but  the wife doesn't know when the final  reveal comes it's nasty and it's harsh  some of the themes that are explored the  fallout from divorce also the sibling  rivalry there's issues of injustice and  fairness she will be at the British  Council on the 27th and 28th of November  please keep looking at our Facebook page  we will be having interviews with Anne  stay tuned  [Music]